northeast india and neighbouring
bangladesh have been hit by heavier than
usual monsoon rains causing widespread
flooding at least nine people have been
killed and two million left homeless in
the indian state of assam
experts say floods following seasonal
rains are increasing due to climate
change
devastating floods unleashed by monsoon
storms
millions of people in bangladesh and
india saw their homes submerged
underwater
the floods have killed dozens in both
countries
families are mourning the death of their
loved ones
this man lost two of his grandchildren
elsewhere relentless rain is making it
harder for people to reach shelter
india's northeastern state of assam is
also particularly hit by flooding and
landslides
rescue teams have been racing to
evacuate stranded villagers
the situation had been a little grim
because there had been heavy rainfall
since the past few days and the whole of
assam is inundated and the quantum
depends
it varies from place to place
but extreme weather has become
increasingly frequent in recent years
and many areas have had little time to
recover before being hit again
this is the third time that we're facing
floods
this time the flood has completely
swamped the streets
whatever was repaired after the second
flood is now again in ruins
while low-lying areas in bangladesh and
india are more prone to such disasters
many believe climate change is making
the situation
well worse now joined by hussein adeeb
the acting director of water aid in
bangladesh he's based in dhaka welcome
to dw um what's the biggest risk now for
the people affected
well thank you very much currently the
situation as it is it's quite intense
and the biggest risk is actually life
livelihood security altogether because
the places have got inundated in a
magnitude which has been unprecedented
over a period of last 122 years so
the places which
have never seen
the water level rising to that extent
are now actually being inundated so
uh there have been a bit of delay in
terms of uh being evacuated and one
great risk is that people are still
actually unaccounted for yet to be
rescued
desperate uh indeed now tell us what is
most needed to
help the situation
right well of course there are some uh
urgent uh response needed first of all
rescue because as i just mentioned that
a good number of people still
unaccounted for and the flood shelters
uh which are quite inadequate given the
magnitude of the crisis at the moment uh
conventionally most of the school
buildings uh are used as plant shelter
other than the
typical flood shelters now in silla
district 50 of schools are inundated so
they are not being able to use that flat
shelter so the immediate need is of
course
food uh shelter there has been power
cuts so in many of the
flood shelters people are actually
living in the dark um security basic
care facilities and very very
importantly clean water and sanitation
now floats dumps off the medium jar
now go ahead
in terms of the medium time because we
expect after a few days even if the
situation will remain grim uh the water
will start to recede and recede and we
will start to see the
real extent of
the disaster and the damage for itself
and
the infrastructure which are already
damaged crops have been washed over the
grains which have been harvested uh
livestock livelihood all together and
water points sanitation facilities being
washed away so a massive
rehabilitation
would require
immediately after uh
after the flood as for medium-term
effort
hussein adebe thank you
thank you